Okay, God willing.
I seek refuge in God from the accursed Satan.
In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most
Merciful. To Him is referred the knowledge of
the Hour. And no
fruit emerges from its sheath, nor does any female conceive or give birth, except with His knowledge. And
on the Day He will call to them, "Where are My
partners?" they will say, "We have been given permission." There is no witness among us. And what they
used to call upon before will vanish from them, and they will think that they have no escape. No
man is spared from
supplication for good, but if evil touches him, he despairs. And if
We let him taste mercy from Us after
adversity has touched him, he will surely say, "
This is against me, and I do not think the Hour will ever come." And
if I am returned to my Lord, I will surely have with Him the best
reward.
Then We will surely inform those who disbelieved of what they did, and We will surely make them taste a severe punishment. And when We bestow favor upon man, he turns away and distances himself;
but when evil touches him, he is full of supplication.
Say, "Have you considered: if it is from God and
you disbelieve in it, who is more astray than one who is in extreme dissension?"
We will show them Our signs in the horizons and within themselves
until it becomes clear to them that it is the truth. Is it not sufficient for your Lord
He is a witness over all things,
yet they are in doubt about meeting
their Lord. He is
encompassing of all things. May God reward you.
Accept the work
that we do and the work
that we are doing
for God, and we hope to see you back
with us very soon.